once again
let's do it
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
to your favorite podcast
[Music]
what's up y'all welcome back to riffin
with Griffin
[Music]
on today's episode of River mcgriffin we
have NBA Finals the Lazarus Project on
TNT want to talk about it like it
and some more exciting Tech news
exciting and scary Bible band in Utah
um a couple other stories you know news
and notes Eric Griffin thoughts but as
usual everybody
welcome back
[Music]
laughs
oh welcome back anyways good to be here
y'all welcome back to riffing with
Griffin it's always a pleasure to have
you uh you know make sure you subscribe
y'all hit the Subscribe button so you uh
you know when I'm going live on
Wednesdays and just you know when I put
up uh shorts or whatever it is you know
all the things to do to help you know on
a twitch uh you twitch people if you
like watching the old man game come
check me out on Twitch I'm on there
daily and if you want to support by
being a patreon member
hey patreon remember just you know
ways to support the old guys so keep me
into business right
so thank you as always for being here on
riffing with Griffin today's episode of
riffing with Griffin is brought to you
by doordash
door Dash summer is around the corner
and picnics beaches pool time all that
stuff look download the doordash app and
enter
rwg summer for 50 off your next door
dash pass subject to change terms apply
all right here we are what's up y'all
thanks for uh being here once again as
always we're from with Griffin you know
how we do it
um
you know what wait as I'm doing as I'm
talking something like that out it's
like
this this is It's just turned into like
a a fun little regular job I've given
myself and I just wait till like you
know get my thoughts out there I might
look back on this later and be like what
was I doing why was I talking about
stuff like that who knows I think I will
I think there's probably episodes where
I don't even know things that I've said
or done and I might look back on it and
be like
oh man it was this
should I have done that you know what I
mean but it is what it is uh we're here
running a little late today because I
just recording a cartoon out here doing
it y'all cartoon it's called Hoagie
brothers so we'll see if that you know I
don't know if it's even coming out I
think it is you know it is what it is so
I'd love to get into the cartoon
business that's great you know people
always say I'm a living cartoon
something Bobby Lee always says about me
I'm a cartoon character I would love to
be on the cartoon be a character on
Family Guy or The Simpsons or something
like that seems like the dream job you
know so you don't necessarily have to be
in the public eye maybe people don't
know exactly who you are but you're just
working I think I enjoyed that about the
business I don't know if I
I often think about that do I do I want
to be super famous do I do I like being
even the little Fame that I have do I
like that is that something that's a
part of something that I want or is it a
byproduct some people want that some
people love the fame they like being
recognized they like being noticed they
just they just love being the that or is
it just about like do you do I like
working like I like being in the
entertainment business like everything I
do I feel like oh yeah I did that I was
able to do that and so and that's all I
like about it and then maybe the the
other part of it is just a byproduct
having to take pictures or you know all
that trolls that hit you up all the
people that you know attack you the
negative side of it I'm saying it's like
that's just you know you have to you you
sign up for it right so I don't know
I just like doing all the things that I
do
um want to shout out again to uh Harlan
Williams I don't know if you guys saw me
on the Harlan Williams podcast but I
just had such a funny time such a fun
time with that guys so you should check
out his podcast funny dude man what a
what a good time and he has a bunch of
my friends that are on there so uh check
out there uh let's see updates here in
the Griffin household we finally got it
we finally got a new bed new mattress uh
we got a Tempur-Pedic you know with the
you know the the what do you call it the
it moves oh I love it I love that it's
like because I have like I like to
listen to audiobooks before I go to bed
I gotta do my book club again too
um you know
shout out to people that like to read
listen to audiobooks read books
um I'm actually I should give a shout
out to this one author Melissa f Olson
she's she's she like uh writes these
modern vampire stories like vampire
witches and werewolves and so she's got
this book series just look her up
Melissa f Olson if you're into that kind
of stuff like vampires in the modern
world
um I just I love the world she creates
and I love her writing style it's very
it's very
it's very fun and adult at the same time
I don't know it's relatable you know
anyways shout out to her book club I'll
do I'll do another book club if you have
a book you think I would like if because
if you've listened to the podcast and
you know the kind of things that I like
to talk about you know hit me up you
know I like when people send me messages
about shows I should watch Yo Griff you
gotta check out this show you'll like it
for the podcast I mean I like I
eventually get to that stuff I I will
get to it so
if you got a good book uh because I'm I
finish audiobooks so fast and then I
have to move on to another one and so
it's just like I listen I listen to
audiobooks the way I watch television
man I watch a lot of shows I listen to a
lot of audio books I like I'm in my car
I never listen to music in my car unless
somebody's in the car you know but but
anyways Griffin household we got a new
mattress uh and I love how anyways what
what was the point I was making oh yeah
so I like to listen to my audiobook and
but I don't like laying flat I get
really uncomfortable so now this thing
it kind of moves I can have it in a sort
of sitting position or like just
slightly have my head raised they had
this like TV mode where you're like like
you're sitting in a chair or something
like that it's great and on my side have
to do with her side it has like snoring
recognition so like if I'm snoring it'll
like start to vibrate and I wake up like
oh I'm snoring or it'll like
automatically move you up like you know
to get you out of that snoring position
Rachel says she wants the remote because
she said you were snoring and it didn't
move so she just wants to remote so she
can move me
I think that's funny you make me wake up
and you're in a completely different
position so that's fun
fun stuff
so yeah
um even though these Tempur-Pedic foam
they have like a certain smell when you
first take them out the box
you know they have this weird smell so I
don't know and I was looking it up and
that is a thing and I think that they um
apparently they it goes away after a few
weeks but Rachel's so sensitive to smell
so it's so funny because she had to have
this mattress right so like when
something like this is going on she
can't say anything and that's why you
know you got that's why like all you
husbands out there
sometimes you just gotta like wait wait
your time like if you didn't like they
want something and you got to decide can
I live with that and a lot of times you
can a lot of times it's like you go uh
that's there's things about you find
things you like and then if it turns out
because it was their choice that there's
something about it that they don't like
zip it they can't say nothing you pick
this you know what I mean
so uh anyways that's all good stuff
going on in the Griffin household
yeah you know what somebody said in a
chat separate rooms
I wonder like
you know what's funny when you get
married like you get married and you've
been living let's say even before you
get married like you're single or you
live by yourself you have an apartment
or you have a roommate but you still
have your own room like there's a whole
thing about like if you have brothers
and sisters maybe you shared a room with
a brother or a sister but then you get
as soon as you become an adult you're
like on your own for the most part right
you either have your own place or maybe
even if you have a roommate you have
your own space
and then for some reason there's you get
used to having your own space your own
stuff then you get someone in your life
and all of a sudden you revert back to
Childhood of like like now you can't
even have your own room your own space
now you have to like like where is it
written
there's some sort of law that you have
to sleep in the same room with your with
your with your spouse
when did that who did that who decided
that and why are we following it you
know I feel like you know and that's why
you end up having your own stuff like
you have like I'm in my office right now
like I have to have my office but then
Rachel was like when we moved and we got
like a bigger place she was like well
this room's mine right so it always
changes at first it was going to be her
yoga room ain't no yoga going on
ah hey not an ounce of yoga going on in
the room I remember one day I walk in
there she's like it's my yoga room so
the yoga mats laid out one of those yoga
balls you know she's sitting on the yoga
ball like no she's laying on the yoga
ball kind of rocking back and forth but
she's looking at Tick Tock and I was
like oh is that the yoga that's going on
so then it went from the yoga room to
like the all multi-purpose room to
announce the shoe room like I said you
know she got a wall of shoes and like
you know what I mean it's just funny but
what I'm saying is I get that idea that
everybody wants kind of their own space
you want your own space you want your
own you know hey this is my thing I
don't know it's a weird thing but you
know there are studies about
sleeping with someone sleeping next to
someone that you really care about love
how it uh
you know it helped it's better for your
health for your longevity how cuddling
and that kind of stuff and there's so
many studies about you know human
interaction and you know so I I mean I
get that too you know you want that as
well so I'm just I have I don't I don't
mind it I like I love that she's there I
love sleeping next to her you know it's
just I just wonder why we do that you
know it's like why do we why it's like
you know you combine everything when
you're an adult you all of a sudden
you're combining everything that you you
you separated for so long and now you're
like oh hey now we have to intertwine
with someone again as if I was a kid
but anyways
somebody said in the chat 32 years old
owned my own house with roommates that I
got kicked out anytime if they start to
become a past ugly oh okay he says he
don't think he'll ever get married ah
you you'll get married
don't let your past experiences of bad
relationships
deter you from meeting someone new
here's my saying for you don't let the
last don't don't don't don't judge the
present because of the last one you know
don't do that
everybody's different every situation is
different
it's so crazy how like
an experience you have with someone's
feels so absolute you know when you're
dating someone and you like you maybe
you're falling in love and you think to
yourself I can there this feeling I
can't ever feel this with anyone else
and that's probably true because that's
so unique with that person but you have
to remember that when you meet someone
else you're gonna have a new unique
experience that could be better or worse
than the last but don't even compare
them because it's like wow but it's like
people so easy to say people say don't
compare you have that knowledge in your
head
so it's like you might go oh here's like
four things I hated about my last
situation
and only one of them is happening now
but then here's six things I love about
this but there were some things I loved
about the you know it's kind of a puzzle
that you're trying to put together
that's probably never gonna be complete
but you just you just you know you find
the right situation and you never know
it's just it's just like you know it
just clicks and it doesn't and it clicks
over time too by the way you almost have
to like kind of you you're with someone
you go oh you know what I could tolerate
this person through the good and bad and
the only way you could do this you have
to have some bad that's what dating is a
relationship being in a relationship you
know it's like you're you're going on
and like something happens and to me
it's like that's the sign like let's say
you go through something terrible and
then you come out the other side you go
oh here's how we handled that I love how
we handled that it's the reason why
Rachel and I got married too is because
of like dealing with the pandemic the
way we did and how we bonded and and
just like living in this situation where
it was like great
comfortable
less there was no pressure there was no
I just felt like oh something you have
to go through something happens and
instead of like thinking about that
thing that's happening sometimes you got
to look back and be like oh you know
what
I like how we handled this and here we
are on the other side
uh
you know this is like so ridiculous
I'm so glad Janine thanks for the super
chat but I have to talk I have to tell
you off now
you know
people love mad life
okay they just do
so now every girl
is hitting me up talking about oh can
you hook me up with Matt
uh it doesn't work like that
this isn't tender this isn't hinged okay
and trust me you know
if you have to meet them like this it
ain't gonna it ain't gonna happen
I just this just reminds me I even may
have talked about this story before but
I've met Justin Bieber a few times in
like these intimate settings at like a
uh his home his own birthday party
you know and so he took a picture of us
and he put it on his Instagram and it
was just crazy amount of attention right
had it on my Instagram I heard that I
was getting messaged by people that know
me and don't know me
talking about hey
can you can you like get me and Bieber
like this one girl I know
I'll never forget this she hits me up
and she's like Hey listen I'm at this
I'm at this club
Bieber's here and we locked eyes for a
second and I know there was a Vibe and
now I can't find him
so can you somehow you know I just I
feel like that connection was there and
I don't want to
you know what I mean you talking about I
was like
if it was meant to be guess what it'll
come back around Universal put y'all
back together
people are crazy
so now it's happening with Matt you know
he's got these pictures all over the
city now with his shirt off
you know freaking he's Ashton Kutcher
video you know what I mean the dudes he
went from Rags to Riches he's like super
famous now
you know it's so crazy it's like
you don't he's always been a little mad
to me like
for years now
that's how I would refer to him oh
little Matt's coming standard dudes a
freaking cheekbones and muscles
you know what I mean he's asking me to
go do shows with him you know
like crazy
he was opening for me
now I you know but I have no ego I love
going on I love going shows with him and
I directed his last special so check
that out I'm sorry Janine it's never
gonna happen okay sorry just it's not
gonna happen
that I say all that to say that
all right
I don't even know what I was talking
about now let's just move on
stream settings wait let me see uh
stream Health user activity but as
always thank you for the Super Chat
I love your support every single week
guys you you know you need to do an
example of what she does okay because
that's just great all right let's go
into comments now let's go into the
comments uh from the the some YouTube
comments
uh let's see
u-u-r-n-n urine whatever
u-u-r-r-n-n is the person's name what a
stupid name that name is dumb
put your damn name on here God I hate
people love this succession talk great
show great recap of the finale
yeah that was a great show I'm sad it's
going away I I I we need more shows that
that way
um oh I love these kind of comments I'm
gonna I don't normally read the negative
comments but I love these kind of dumb
hater comments from Billy ray2885. he
seems so awkward with her did he kidnap
her it would explain how he got a dime
piece oh
your jealousy sustains me
iPhone blast like mine is and let me see
like like let me let me imagine you you
having you doing a video you have
pictures with your spouse and then some
[__] on the internet has some
negative [__] to say about it you know
imagine like your the feeling of that
y'all don't know how it is y'all don't
know how it is to have your business out
in the streets and then people
constantly
so Billy Ray you can eat my ass how
about that
um
let's see
all right
um let me see I had I had him now what
happened to my I had them all ready to
go
uh let's see here
um
just Edward
longgrass weird ass name too he said I
love this [__] that's great sometimes
that's all you got to put
[Laughter]
uh
uh let's see where are we at oh somebody
said the laser eight Caleb Martin went
to my university I would see him walking
around campus I never thought I'd see
him making impact in the league so soon
it's crazy to see wow I know imagine
somebody that you know
you know and then either then you see
them go that's what happens though when
you see somebody you know from your
school they go on and get famous or they
do movies or they're a professional
athlete or just things you know what I
mean it's like it's crazy to see people
like that
um let's see here oh somebody commented
and this is a comment because I put up a
post about Harlan Williams podcast and
he goes I've never uh Fern 6306 never
seen anyone make you laugh like this
yeah Harlan Williams really made me made
me laugh
let's see now here's an idiot comment I
mean just
I just I love when people are telling me
I was talking about my aunt
my aunt I remember my aunt you know and
I just made up the number I don't know
what channel it was okay but my aunt
she's looking at the T she's never had a
TV before and she has a TV and she told
me not to turn it to one station because
it was because King Kong was on and it
was she imagine you've never seen TV
before and you see a big ass gorilla you
know grabbing white women you know uh so
this guy fibo Lenco 3995 no Eric your
relative in Belize wasn't worried about
King Kong many places consider their
number 13 as the devil's number in
Australia many streets don't have 13
many hotels don't have the 13th floor
okay I'm not going to continue on with
this comment but that's something ever
like in the United States that's still a
thing in the United States I don't know
if
older buildings they they've never had a
13th floor they always skip it for some
reason like that was a it wasn't the
devil's number it was considered an
unlucky number you know 13 is that I
don't you know what I don't hear about
that that much anymore but that used to
be a big thing where 13 was an unlucky
number I haven't even thought about it
like that in a long ass time you know
and anybody remember that yeah that's
like an old school thing that's one of
those things that you kind of just
people kind of just move on you know
um
let's see what we got here uh let me see
Joe ball 13 I love his character of
Montez so much that I feel like he owns
it now no matter how they wrote it he
was so believable that I was actually
disappointed when I heard him talk
outside of the show
it's a long long comment the guy's got
four or five long-ass comments it's like
dude nobody nobody's reading all this
you know like it's like sometimes I'll
get like a 10 paragraph Instagram
message
and then they get mad cause like oh you
didn't read this you How You Gonna Leave
Me on scene [__] I didn't read that as
soon as I opened it and saw it I was
like next nobody's reading all your long
ass diatribes what are you talking about
you know
not necessarily that guy but just in
general like the guy wrote three
paragraphs on the YouTube comment so
who's reading that not me
all right well we're done that's enough
comments for for this time
um
you know like I say thanks for being
here Sean on thanks for the Super Chat
he said love the content you were the
first comedian I ever saw live eight
years ago at bananas in Jersey
they always ask me to come to St Louis
yeah yeah wow that was so long ago man
eight years ago makes me feel like I'm
old I've been into business too long I
feel like right yeah but thanks for
being here guys all right um you know
what let's get back to the sponsor of
the show you know
um I love doordash Rachel and I use
doordash all the time for many number of
things but the big thing now is summer
is around the corner and it might be the
best time of the year for some people I
think so doordash the dash pass from
doordash with the dash pass membership
you could say big now through July 19th
on swimsuits Beach snacks sunscreen and
more because that's the kind of stuff
you can get from doordash you know you
get you get you about to go to the beach
you forgot to buy everything
your door Dash it all the stuff you need
for the beach comes
it's finally time for pool parties
backyard barbecues and Outdoor
Adventures with dash pass membership
from doordash you can you can best your
best summer with members only offers
drops and events now through July 19th
but that's not all you also get access
to thousands of offers Nationwide
ensuring that this summer is one two
remember
so once a year it's a great event
thanks to you know thanks to doordash
and door dash pass you won't miss a beat
if there's anything that you need you
could just get it experience a summer
like no other best best your best summer
with dash pass membership with doordash
today sign up for dash pass now and
you'll get your first month free plus
when you use our promo code get 50 off
up to ten dollar value when you spend 15
or more on your next dash pass order
when you download the doordash app and
enter code
rwg summer Riven with Griffin summer rwg
summer that's 50 off when you spend ten
dollars or more on your next dash pass
order with the download when you
download the doordash app and enter code
rwg summer don't forget code rwg summer
for 50 off your next order subject to
change terms apply
okay good people and trolls
um let's talk about some stuff now let's
get into what's happening in the world
um you know I saw this story and I
thought man this is I don't even know
what to I don't even know what to make
of this man but it's like
this is this is just what goes on in the
world right now you know
so in Utah
the Bible is banned from Utah schools
after parents demand its removal wow and
that's something world we live in now
the parent wrote the Bible's incest
onanism did I say that right bestiality
prostitution General communication
fellatio dildos rape such and such go on
on and on you know you know a lot of
Bible stories you know stories in the
Bible
the Utah School District banned the
Bible from its Elementary School and
Middle School libraries for containing
vulgarity and violence
okay
look
I don't know what kind of world we
living in now okay like I just
like if this is what we're gonna do look
it's like
I'm not a huge Bible guy even if I'm
spiritual you know what I believe or not
believe if you believe in God or don't
believe in God whatever your thing is
whether you're Jewish Christian whatever
it is you know it's like
removing this I don't know if like to me
were they removing this because they
believe this things that they're saying
about it or is it just like this is the
kind of thing people like to do to exert
some control to like stir up trouble to
like cause dissension you know
especially in a place like Utah where
like Mormonism is like so heavy there
and that religion can be a bat [__] okay
so for them to be like look at this
Bible and be like oh we got to get rid
of this I mean these are stories you
know it's like the history of the Bible
is Rich history whether you believe all
the stuff in it or not a lot of I mean
if you're gonna get rid of the Bible
then you shouldn't then John Wick
shouldn't be in movie theaters in Utah
or even The Lion King when you know you
got you got the uncle you know trying to
kill the kid and killed his brother you
know what I mean it's like what are we
talking about you know saying it's like
then you can look at anything you can
look at anything and everything and find
something that you could be like we got
to keep kids away from this as opposed
to like you know where there's no
accountability for people to be like yo
hey parents out there let's talk to your
kids that's like you know I don't know
man I just feel like if you're
our Christian family and you're in Utah
and you're religious and you follow the
Bible and you're you're teaching your
kids this and that about uh how what
these stories mean and stuff like that
and now at the schools they've just
taken it away and they've used all these
words now I mean if you're a kid and you
find out you go well what's all this
stuff as opposed to like the essence of
what it was it's really about just the
unknown try to explain our existence
trying to you know explain why you know
there's a there's a higher power out
there and and this is what
and and and this is a way to explain
like I say why we're here and why we
interact with each other and rules we
should follow and how we should treat
each other and the only way you can
display like here is you know here's
what good people do you have to show
some of the things that bad people do
that's how you can know the difference
you know it's like we go hey these
people did this and now we want you to
do this instead I don't know I just
don't know if you want to do we want to
be in a world where we're censoring
everything we're taking anything out any
kind of images any anything at all that
just complete like even something
innocuous you're gonna be like let's get
rid of that because kids might think
this as opposed to like you know
helping people learn how to think for
themselves and uh you know different
thoughts different ideas I just I just
don't know man I mean I'm trying to have
kids so it's like
what what am I gonna think later if you
know my kid comes back from school and
he's like you know hey Dad how come you
know how come the Bible these brother
and sister were getting together what's
up with that you know what I mean it's
like I don't know but I would hope that
I have an environment where
maybe that's what you want is your kids
to come ask you to questions I just
think they were so afraid to answer the
questions I think we don't people don't
you know I we're making people grow up
too fast and I get that too so it's like
it's a nuanced situation there's my
favorite word nuance everybody take a
drink
um
but I went to Catholic school myself my
whole life you know I'm not Catholic but
I went to Catholic School I've been to
religious schools and you know you had
to even when you didn't want to go to
mass even if you mastered me anything so
you know you had to go because it was
part of the curriculum of the school you
know we took religion in school we took
like you know I mean because that's
that's school that's what they taught so
it's like
the idea that you're just gonna take the
Bible out because there's stuff in it
that you don't like I mean this is what
we're doing in society where you know
you know the the you know these uh you
know
they don't want you to say slavery
anymore they don't want you to stay
homeless anymore then you know we can't
say man we can't say women we can't say
like all these things are trying to
change and take away as opposed to like
hey let's have a discussion of why why
we feel this way you know let's talk
about these things so I don't know I
just thought this was like one of those
weird ass topics man where I'm just like
man where what what's going on next but
you know again you think about it and
you just think about what's people's
motivation you know
and I sometimes like you never watch
like one of those shows like Oprah or
like you know Dr Phil or something like
that you know now have somebody on there
talking about a hot button subject and
you wonder are they talking about this
hot button subject because they
passionately feel that it's right or
wrong or they just talking about it to
be seen as someone who's talking about
it I think there's a lot of that going
on on the internet a lot of that going
on out there in the world where it's
like even if it's crazy stuff it's like
those people that are like I renounce my
white privilege
those videos
are these real Lefty liberals like super
like super duper left people who are
like
I renounce my white privilege
only white privilege
can
we would you be able to say that you
would have to have extreme white
privilege to be like I'm getting rid of
my white privilege
as if the other side could do that I
renounce the racism against me so it's
gone now no one
just it's that kind of thing so I don't
know I often wonder why people you have
to you have to question people's
motivations sometimes you know it's like
and that's why but and again that's why
discussion is needed I just think that
discussion is needed in these situations
man
all right I've been watching this uh
I've been watching this show man it's
called The Lazarus Project I want to go
to this website but I feel like they're
showing video into YouTube gets real
weird about this man but yeah so this is
like the Lazarus Project it's on uh
it's on what do you call it
TNT
um I like it
you know I like this show oh they're
doing a giveaway I don't know why I'm
doing uh I don't know this isn't a good
website I'm showing you guys but if
you're listening at home it doesn't
matter if you're listening in a car or
whatever you don't get it doesn't matter
if you see this or not but anyways
Lazarus Project it's about
like a secret a secret government
organization
um
let me look it up here
and oh here we go this is better the
IMDb is always better I don't know why I
went to TNT I mean it's a TNT's website
you know so anyways here we go so this
is uh yeah so what is it about it's a
top secret organization
dedicated
um dedicated to preventing mass
extinction and events with the ability
to make time go backwards
so you know I love this kind of techy
nerdy time travel secret organization
spy stuff and this is what this is
Lazarus Project and a starring Papa
assidu I don't know what just I don't
know if I even said that guy's name
right and a bunch of other like it's
very ethnic
you know what I mean let's just say that
you know by the way have no problem with
it like
this is one of these examples of like
you know the pendulum swinging in a
right in in a perfect amount okay it's
like it it has to make sense as long as
it makes sense I'm okay with it you know
when you try to change Peter Pan to
Peter Pan and Wendy and all of a sudden
everybody's ethnic just out of nowhere
and it don't make sense when we're
talking about mid-century England you
know what I'm trying to say like that's
when you kind of go wait wait what are
you doing we just want it to make sense
it's okay if like in the 1700s everybody
was white in whatever show you're doing
and I'm fine with that because it makes
sense of what you're talking about you
know but if you're like this it's modern
day yeah dude's black he's from wherever
they're in London or whatever you know
the lady that runs and thinks she's
Indian and you're just like you don't
even think about it you know what I mean
you're just kind of like oh okay yeah
that's smart and you know this is uh
this is this you know you just don't
even when they do it right you don't
even thinking about it you know but you
can't just like there's somebody said in
the thing removing all logic yeah you
cannot do that you can't you can't you
can't just be like oh yeah here's uh you
know there's a family of black people
that live in like on the it's like what
like a Beauty and the Beast there's this
little mid-century French town and all
of a sudden there's like just a group of
black people that live there all of a
sudden where they come from I don't know
it's just when that kind of stuff when
it makes you think that it go you didn't
do this right I get what you're trying
to do and I applaud you for trying to be
good people and trying to have
representation and a diversity but just
make it make sense all right let me get
off that tangent I love this show so far
I've only seen one episode so in the
episode
and this is not even really a spoiler so
much it's like it's a it's gonna be an
episodic so there's gonna be 20 episodes
okay so if I give you a little bit of
what's going on maybe you'll want to
watch it okay so this guy is living his
life okay he's living his life seems
like a good dude he's got a great idea
he has a meeting at the bank and he goes
and he's got a beautiful wife and then
you know you're following his
relationship he you know you know he's
living his good life and then all of a
sudden
you know everything goes terrible
something bad is going happening and
you're watching him live through it and
then one day he just wakes up and it's
six months earlier
and he's like whoa and now he's living
this six months again but now he's like
well wait a minute this already happened
and he knows something terrible is about
to happen so now he's going crazy
Cassandra Cass syndrome or whatever they
call that Cassandra something it's like
when you know the future how do you stop
it you can't stop it you know and then
people think you're crazy you know what
I mean people think you're crazy you
know and so then like
he lives the six months again
and then it's like this organization
finds him and they're like yo you have a
secret thing that you're able to do this
and I you know we need you to come work
for us and then you know
whatever then you start to find out
about the organization in the world and
it's like I like it like I I I like this
I I can follow along with this uh I
think it's set up great I think there's
a great overall concept of the show so
this organization is you know they they
time jump they they they time bring time
back so they can solve problems you know
they have a whole sciency explanation
about how it works and it makes sense
even if it's not feasible but any just
make me believe you know let me suspend
my disbelief so they you know do this
thing and then you know now it's just
about the people in it so now you can
have a bunch of like B stories every
week
you know and then our overall story of
like of course anytime there's an
organization like this there's Rogue
members that know about it and they're
trying to destroy the world or they're
trying to like win the lottery or
whatever it is I'm just assuming you
know that I I could see where it could
go and it's all very interesting you
know but here 's something I want to
bring up that I saw in this show and
this is this the reason why I want to
talk about this show so I like the show
I'm giving it like eight woo-woos
okay so I highly recommend you watch the
first episode and I guarantee you that I
bet the first five to ten episodes are
really gonna be good and can they
continue that you know can they continue
it it's gonna be the thing that's hard
to do because it's a big concept and it
has to be a story that we have to follow
it's like The Silo on Apple TV which I
also recommend I've talked about it
already but it is good and I'm just
waiting to see
what's in what's going on where it's
going where it's going to lead I think
Lazarus Project is the same kind of
thing but here's something I want to
bring up that happened in the Lazarus
Project okay and I'm gonna talk about it
like this first
um
one of the things I really love about
the United States
is that we celebrate our triumphs and
our tragedies the same way
we make a movie or a television show
that's how we do it if something really
terrible happens I guarantee you that
[__] will end up in a movie
it'll be a plot point in a movie and I'm
not talking about like a documentary
movie I'm not talking about like a you
know a reenactment of real events I'm
talking about we will use that [__] in
fiction
911 was one of the worst things to ever
happen in the United States all right
just psychologically how it affected us
the people that died the memories of it
911 is a plot point in dumb spy movies
all the time now
as if okay well we're gonna take it
we're going to use it if that's not a go
[__] yourself to the people that hate
the United States
like imagine you're you're a terrorist
group and you're trying to like
you know oh we're gonna show them trust
me whatever you did we're gonna get over
it and we're gonna put it in the
Avengers that's what we do
Boston Marathon bombing 9 11. just so
many different things and they did it in
the Lazarus Project with this
so you know they're stopping terrible
things that happen and just casually the
guy says in the show and I'm just a
spoiler but whatever it's only it's only
one sentence okay so it doesn't matter
right if you're one of those people
Griffin stubs spoiling shows yeah
whatever stop watching my podcast
um the guy says when when he's getting
ex they're explaining to him what the
Lazarus Project is and he says casually
well why didn't you stop the Coronavirus
and she says back
we got a vaccine in nine months
what do you think how do you think we
did that and I was mind blown man I was
mind blown because I was like wow
already
coronavirus is just a plot point in a
show
thousands of people died
ah it ruined our lives for two years it
ruined restaurants and businesses and
you know just all the things that came
about it just the politics of it
everything and here's this little TNT
science fiction show and they just
throwing it out like a little plot Point
like oh yeah boom and I thought that is
the resilience of the human Spirit
really
of human beings of the United States and
maybe other places are doing the same
thing man in other places like we're the
enemy and they're defeating us in their
movies but
in our movies television shows it's like
Bin Laden we made a move we made a movie
about Bin Laden so fast I thought that
was Bin Laden's body
in the movie
Bin Laden 911 the you know Waco it's
like there's so many like even making a
movie like sort of like telling the
story of some tragedy even that could be
disrespectful in a way you know like you
just making a movie uh uh and then you
putting pretty people in it too it's all
cute actors and stuff in some thing
where you go well so I guess no ugly
people got affected by 9 11. you know
what I mean I think I've talked about
this before on a previous episode
because it's like I'm having Deja Vu
about it so I don't want to go on and on
about it because I probably already made
the same points but my point now is
Lazarus Project is good and it's just
like it's a real sign that we we've
completely moved on we have moved on
from everything that happened from 2019
on
it's some terrible things happen but
here we are and now it's a plot point in
a television show so I thought that was
interesting
okay let's see what else we got here oh
man I got a lot of these little stories
on the internet let's just go quick
through some of these now so apparently
Apple says it in its new operating
software that it put an end to
everyone's ducking autocorrect
I mean Mary you know when you're trying
to write some bad words and it changes
it to stuff that you don't want
apparently apple is aware of it and
they're like all right man we're gonna
let you do this now you know
we're gonna we're gonna let you do this
uh
just put somebody in timeout and chat
that's funny I like doing that I will
time you out if you say something that
that I think is dumb
so at this thing like this is where
science is going man a lot of technology
stuff right now so I think that the
iPhone is like finally Gonna Let You
Like
you know I always feel like the auto
correct and the voice The Voice
um voice thing you know when you voice
chat you know or voice to chat voice to
text that voice to text never works
right you ever try it you're doing it
and you say a big ass paragraph then you
send it and then you look at it and you
go oh man that's not what I said so it's
like that technology still is a little
funky it's amazing how advanced
technology is in other areas but they
can't get that voice to text right
that's weird and this auto correct thing
I can't stand when I'm typing something
and it just changes it like it's like as
if you can't write a word like you can't
write someone's name that's looks
similar to a word so apparently they're
finally
um
they're finally going to do it and
here's another one in other Tech News
man and this is like we've been talking
a lot on the podcast about AI so
apparently this is like a real thing
that's happening man and it's something
to think about but nearly 4 000 jobs
were lost to AI last month
this report shows so you know like IBM
and stuff and uh
a lot of these like different base
companies are using you know certain
jobs they go well I think an AI or
computer could do this better especially
if it has to do with like mathematics or
like counting or like keeping track of
things and it's just like man I mean
that's pretty scary huh
I mean that's like is that it's like is
that where we're going with it man so
but
I've talked about this before and I'll
continue to talk about it is that I
think that we're gonna really have to
change
how we learn how we Implement these
things into society how like the kind of
professions that you know you go after I
mean it's like if you want to be a
photographer now I mean if you were one
of those people that used to develop
pictures I mean that whole industry is
gone
you know it's like I still don't
understand why we're taking passport
pictures I don't know why we have to pay
for passport pictures that's a racket
that they can't let go of
okay I could take a goddamn picture with
my iPhone and you can use that [__]
okay stop with this like special picture
we need at CVS of your passport what the
hell man you know the fact that they're
still doing that is so annoying it's
like this this selfie with this 4k
camera is fine
so that's one of those things where you
go
not that that's a profession imagine if
you were like yo I'm going into passport
photos
it's gonna be my new profession but it's
like stop what are we talking about you
know
it's like you know you you do what you
do man
so you're gonna have to like when you're
in school now you have to think of like
computers
sort of program programming and you know
how to use there's gonna be a whole
professions of like in incorporating AI
into what you do I mean oh man it's just
gonna be something that we do man
you know it's like
maybe you use AI to like research now
you're gonna be like let's say I want to
I want to do jokes about a topic I might
be like hey I tell me seven things about
you know passport photos and so I can do
a bit
and then you're then the AI is going to
be your writing partner it's going to be
working with you throwing out ideas what
about this Eric can I be like oh I think
that's funny but let me move that to
this move this to here you know it's
like it's like an Iron Man or The
Avengers right it's like the Avengers
when Tony Stark in the end game it's
great you know when he figures out the
time travel that's gonna be how we're
gonna interact with AI you're smart so
here's [__] Tony Stark he's like all
right move this thing over here uh
switch that with that okay I like and
we're gonna be looking at it like this
because you y'all see the Apple glasses
are coming out the VR glasses and it's
like using your eyes and it's using your
hand movements and stuff and it's gonna
be like Minority Report like Avengers
where the shit's gonna be in front of us
this is like virtual reality is going to
be right in front of like you know uh
you know what what do they call it kind
of reality like
um um um
um not virtual reality give me the word
people something reality it's gonna be
right in front of us so interacting and
so that's just how AI is going to be so
I might be like talking with my AI uh
and we're gonna be like no the Google
Glasses was trash chat I had a pair of
Google Glasses it was so stupid because
it was dumb these glasses at Google the
Apple are coming out with are gonna look
just like my glasses you're just going
augmented reality that's the word yes I
did it before you guys told me augmented
reality that's gonna be oh I beat you
Sean in the chat I said it before you
guys did that good
so you had the augmented reality so
that's going to be like the future man
and AI is going to be a part of that you
know so let's say I'm writing jokes I'm
gonna be like hey how this thing
happened to me today I thought that was
funny so give me the origins of that AI
so I think it's just gonna make us more
thoughtful smarter have more access to
information uh you know but it's gonna
make our jobs easier better we have to
start thinking about it like that and so
that's just one of the things and and
and that being said speaking of when I
look at stories about Ai and how
technology is interacting with the world
this is one of the ones where I saw
here's a great story about Ai and even
even last week I was talking about Elon
Musk and his brain implants there is an
upside and here's one of them this brain
implant helped a paralyzed man walk for
the first time in 12 years wow
I mean what are we talking about you
know
so for every bad thing you think is
going to happen of like you know the
government's putting chips in our heads
so they can track our every move and
thought
there's also this
there's also this a guy who couldn't
walk is now walking because he's got
implants in his spine and implants in
his head
it's a 40 year old man and he was
paralyzed legs is now able to walk climb
stairs and move over ramps thanks to
implants in his brain and his spinal
cord
I mean that's amazing man
and I think that we need to start
looking at technology in this way you
know like it's not all gonna be terrible
people are gonna use it for terrible
things because human beings can be trash
the fact that I have trolls in my chat
they're the ones those are the kind of
people who are going to use it for evil
you know they're using the internet for
evil you know what I mean anytime you're
being a bully anytime you're being that
so that's an example of it right there a
small example it's not lemons to lemons
but in this case right here you're
talking about man I've said it before
and I'll say it again I think about my
mom and and and and having dementia
I mean if there was a chip or implant
that like she could get herself back it
could clear her thoughts
I I would trade that for anything
so whatever evils people are going to
use this for if I could get my mom back
okay
I'm not trying to be emotional but
anyways you get my point guys you know
what I mean
you get my point
um
and here's other uses of like weird
technology this one I thought was like a
weird ass story it's that this one is
Japan has introduced vending machines
that automatically offer free food if an
earthquake hits
now this gave me some thoughts
so are you telling me there's vending
machines full of food just sitting there
and you go up to it because you hungry
and they're like well you can't use this
one unless there's an earthquake
I mean that's so specific
[Laughter]
go get dirty panties in a in a so is
that like the row of vending machines
it's like you walk in and you're like oh
what we looking for all right we got
dirty panties all right oh [__] are you
hungry oh no that's the earthquake one
uh you go over and it's like oh that's
the tsunami machine damn it is there
like a just regular ass day vending
machine oh there it is there's a wreck
oh oh no this one is if you know
there was a Mudslide it's like what kind
of like
the weirdest thing
so weird
it's so weird but I thought okay I mean
do earthquakes happen that often that
they felt like you know in the event
there's an earthquake now is it just
like a vending machine they're free too
or is it like oh they had an earthquake
and then you like you go to the vending
machine they're like
[Music]
you know you know it's shaking we gotta
get some food you know like I don't I
don't know
that just seems weird
you know weird thoughts here we're from
a girlfriend but gay anyways guys that's
a good stopping point uh love y'all Chad
thanks for being reacting love all that
and as always you know thanks for being
a part of
riffing with Griffin which we do every
week on Wednesdays
um again I love your comments I love
your interactions thanks for all the
super chats thanks for all the the the
comments you know and please comment on
any of the things that we talked about
if you just have a you know a good
comment I I might end up reading the
comment on the podcast or even
interacting with the comment on YouTube
itself please leave some comments on
Apple and Google Play and all that stuff
that you know people can leave comments
because that stuff is
that stuff's helpful too for the for the
algorithm uh so you know make sure you
sub hit the Subscribe button
make sure you subscribe to the show so
you can hit the notifications I'm on
Twitch on most days so make sure you
come check me out on Twitch love doing
that and also here too with um
on uh what you call it on patreon I'm
I'm doing stuff there too so thank you
very much and as you know when we do the
rap recap if you would like to send a
beat for the rap recap you can email me
at Eric Griffin
ericgirlfriend.com and hit me with in
the subject of a this is a rap recap
beat I'm gonna be in
Tennessee y'all I'm going to Nashville
June 21st I'll be in Nashville for one
night I really want to sell this out
right because they didn't give me the
whole weekend in Nashville so let's come
out on a Wednesday and get this in let's
go Nashville I want to see you guys and
then the for that weekend Thursday
Friday Saturday I will be in Huntsville
in Alabama in Huntsville great Club
great little town so if anybody's out
there you come on out to see my show too
I would I would like to see you let's
let's get it in you know what I mean
okay y'all
you know what time it is
it's that rap recap
Harry G
h
you know how we do
every week
[Music]
we got to talk about the NBA
gotta take that out of the title oh it's
gonna be confusing it's vital
check out Tech news
all you fools
get those panties in there
in the vending machine
make sure they lean
and stinky feet
you know what that's all I got this week
I forgot to talk about the NBA this week
and so we will talk about the NBA next
week let's see what happens by then next
week I think there will be an NBA
champion and we will uh you know we
would talk about it so
anyways guys thanks for being here once
again I'm working with Griffin and I'll
see you next week
[Music]